[Music]
in case you missed it I'm just back from
a whopping 10 day social media and news
hiatus yeah believe it or not it is true
I did not look at my Twitter feed or
follow current events or anything for 10
whole days amazingly going offline for
more than a couple hours seems like a
superhuman feat these days doesn't it
just having one single day without
looking at your phone without reading
the news and without reacting to someone
else's opinion most likely someone else
you've never even met is becoming
increasingly rare these days
this rarity the ability to live life
without being constantly connected is
going to become more and more important
as our physical world continues to
collide with the digital world we're so
connected these days that we can't stop
the onslaught of information for any
amount of time that would allow us to
figure out what's important and what is
irrelevant or perhaps even more
importantly than that what's fact and
what's fiction it's very obvious to me
that occasionally pausing this endless
stream of noise is going to be one of
the biggest challenges that faces
humanity in the next decade this
challenge will be vital not only for
Millennials but for old time Gen Xers
like me as well as the baby boomers who
came before us as for the kids growing
up with an iPad and the crib well good
luck with all that
by doing pretty much nothing on my
vacation besides laying at the beach
going fishing and taking bike rides I
was able to reset a little of this
mental clutter this reset was kind of
tough for the first couple days even
though I tested my off-the-grid skills
less than a year ago last time in some
of you may remember this I literally
locked my phone in a safe for a week to
disconnect but this time I just put my
phone on a shelf in the closet in a
shoebox under a couple other boxes I
guess that's some sort of progress right
there the first couple days I had the
knee-jerk reaction to go to my pocket
and look at my phone for no reason at
all on more than one occasion
eventually that wore off and I found a
strange sense of freedom in not being
online by the final days of my vacation
part of me didn't even want to come back
online at all you're not here I am
apparently the world didn't stop
while I was off the grid from the Milo
scandal to this Trump CNN Fiasco with
the press briefings to the Oscars best
picture screw up the world kept on
spinning along if you missed it I did a
live stream this past Monday with my
thoughts on some of the craziness I
missed and we'll post a link to that
right down below put it aside these
specific news stories and current events
I noticed something else as I
disconnected from the matrix I actually
felt calmer more present and generally
happier by being offline now maybe this
had a little something to do with the
beach that I was on and the margaritas I
was drinking but it wasn't just that I
don't think that our brains are wired to
be taking in endless amounts of
information all the time just think 200
years ago to get a message from London
to New York you had to write a letter
get it on a boat wait a couple weeks for
it to get there and then wait another
couple weeks for the response to get
back across the pond to you a hundred
years ago our fastest communication was
a relatively new invention known as the
telephone which now seems totally
archaic 50 years ago we only had a
handful of television channels and 20
years ago cell phones were so big they
made Zack Morris's phone on Saved by the
Bell looks small soon enough you'll be
able to live stream video aboard a
supersonic plane that will take you from
New York to London in about 20 minutes
the point is the world is now speeding
up at an incredible pace and our own
evolution the ability for our minds to
evolve along with the technology isn't
changing at the same pace I believe this
goes a long way to explaining why people
are constantly outraged and always ready
to fight with random strangers online
our connectivity is evolving faster than
our conscience there's no way for us to
stop scientific progress and I would
never be forward if there was but we can
certainly try to deal with its side
effects more effectively and by the way
you've all heard me say how incredible
this online connection can be it's how
you guys got to me right here this is
the irony of our current situation we
all have an awesome power at our
fingertips but it's up to us what to do
with it as Uncle Ben said to Peter
Parker with great power comes great
responsibility
talking or
or appropriately fighting about politics
endlessly isn't good for our brains or
for our society one of the reasons that
I talk about small government so much is
because I believe that a good government
is one that you don't have to think
about too often and if you don't have to
think about it too often you don't have
to tweet about it every five seconds or
write endless Facebook diatribes about
it either if the government doesn't have
too much control over your life you
don't have to fixate over it's every
move or every policy that it Institute's
this is always an incredible irony of
the progressive ideology they constantly
complain about how the government
operates but their solution is always to
make the government bigger if only their
guys were in charge then we'd have some
sort of magical utopia this isn't only
childish thinking it's also just against
human nature itself the only way to rear
in power is to rear it in regardless of
who's in charge the feeling that we all
have to comment on every news story to
fight over every political point and to
debate every little issue is exactly why
a smaller government would be better
these days don't like Trump the answer
isn't try to upend democracy the answer
is try to rein in the power of
government if we could only live and let
live as our founders intended we would
spend less time worrying fighting and
distracting ourselves from our own lives
so to wrap this up on deleting this
channel closing my Twitter account and
shutting down my Facebook I think we've
had a pretty great run here over at the
Rubin report but nothing lasts forever
all right you got me I'm just kidding
but what I will do is make a renewed
commitment not to add meaningless noise
to your already hectic life now share
this video with everyone you know or the
world as you know it will come to a
horrific end
[Music]
you